and he produced a contract
and he took his finger and slashed her
finger and had her sign in her blood
and then he touched the contract and it
burst into flames and the ashes fell on
the floor so Robert Johnson is there at
the delta in Mississippi he wants to be
the best blues guitarist ever and he
sells his soul to the devil at least
that's what some
album executive said decades later he
can't really sell a soul
so there instead it's just the person
inviting the devil in to their body yep
okay yeah when you make a deal
with the devil it's an invitation and he
takes the invitation very seriously he
comes right in
um one of the worst cases I've ever
heard was from The Exodus of New York
City back about 15 years ago
he was telling me well it would have
been longer than that maybe 2025.
um
there was a woman a young girl Juilliard
a violinist and she was about to
graduate she was brilliantly talented
but all of her friends were getting job
offers and she had none and her friends
remember always hearing her say the
words I would do anything to be famous
well guess who's listening
your angels listening but also there's
other things in the room and it wasn't
long after that that she went to bed one
night had a dream
and she said in the dream was the most
beautiful man she'd ever seen naked
another sign calling card of the devil
uh and he said do you really want fame
and power and she said I do and he
produced a contract
and he took his finger and slashed her
finger and had her sign it in her blood
and then he touched the contract and it
burst into flames and the ashes fell on
the floor
so pretty easy to understand what
happened right you don't need an
advanced literary right
so when you wake up from that dream and
you remember it you might
take a pause and be like I don't think
that was a good thing but what's worse
is her finger was cut and the ashes were
next to the bag
so
she still doesn't say anything
not to be the Devil's Advocate but I
guess to be the devil's advocate
could this girl just have been nuts
making it up or just uh
she could have been she could have yeah
but you have to hear the whole story
okay So within a couple of weeks she
signs this multi-national tour
makes a ton of money becomes very
popular and famous on this circuit and
within a few years she gets involved
with drugs goes to Needles gets HIV now
she's dying in a New York Hospital
and this whole thing comes back to how
this started and she calls her Filipino
mother
and tells her the story
and mommy calls the Chancery hysterical
I need an exodus right away from my
daughter
so Jim is The Exodus he shows up and
they tell him the whole story from the
dream Ford and he says okay well that's
not good you signed a blood Covenant
with the Devil
so I'm going to need you to
break that with the blood Covenant so
you're going to write out the whole
Creed and then you're going to sign in
your blood
well the doctors like she has AIDS she's
not signing anything in blood not gonna
happen and he says well then you need to
step out of the room because she needs
to do this
and she did do it and she signed the
contract the Creed and um within a few
seconds agreed for those who don't know
us I believe in God what we believe is
as our faith yeah the whole faith in a
neat little package
and she signs it
and she convulses and flat lines
and dies
so now the doctor comes back and he's
really upset the mother is out of her
mind they're all blaming the priest
hysteria goes on for about 10 minutes
and then all of a sudden she jumps up
off the table
she's back
oh and they test her
no HIV no AIDS she's completely healed
and so she then committed for the rest
of her life to only
do music that would honor God and to
tell people about the reality of the
devil and not to make deals with them
what's so crazy about the story is there
are so many stories that are I had not
heard that that story
I don't I'm trying to think even if I
reading some of you know your writing
and but
wow
hearing that
I'm
struck but then I think well there are
all these Miracles that have happened
throughout history and then what
hits me is
how do people not believe in the face of
all of this well even I was just at a
conference on signs and wonders
once I was thinking of all these little
coincidences these improbables perhaps
naturally impossible things that
everybody has experienced at some point
in his or her life yeah and when they
strike you you're so hit by them and
then five seconds later you just go on
with your life and you it's as though
they never happened yeah so then I'm
actually less surprised that people
could hear a story like that and and not
believe yeah I think a third of the
people
if you picked up a mountain and moved it
over there a third of the people believe
right away a third of the people will
say it never happened it was always over
there and the third and they'll be
confused and I think that's just the way
human nature pans out I've been pretty
blessed in my life I've seen so many
miracles I mean so many that I expect
them now
I used to be a contemplative hermit just
praying with the woods with a group of
Hermits for the most of the day and when
during that time
the Lord one day said to me he said the
days are fast approaching
when the extraordinary will seem
ordinary
the extraordinary will seem ordinary
meaning like the miraculous will be so
prevalent for what I'm going to do that
it will start to seem ordinary
but don't ever take it ordinary because
it's all Grace and you have to always
acknowledge that this is a great gift
and um
they're just so many I mean even the
smallest little things like there's a
none I'm friends with in manjugori this
place in Bosnia
she
the beautiful Community called the
community the Beatitudes I think they
have a chapter in Denver and they were
in charge of providing dessert for an
orphanage there's like 250 kids coming
for a barbecue picnic thing and the nuns
were doing the dessert and so this one
nun she put in charge of the dessert
got a sample pack of like 12 pudding
cups said will this be okay
and she says oh yes wonderful make sure
we have enough
and the nun who was purchasing them got
the day wrong
and she thought the barbecue was going
to be the following day and they hadn't
arrived when the kids showed up and she
said we have a big problem because you
know I don't have the pudding cups
she's like well they we have all the
other food I mean they're going to eat
but put out the 12-pack at the end of
the table
and she goes well that's going to be
terrible like only 12 kids will get all
the other kids will feel better she goes
just put it out
she puts it out
in all 250 kids go through and every kid
has a pudding cup
and she looks at me and she says you
know what the best part of this is
he didn't just multiply the food he
multiplied the plastic cups
and I go sister why is that a good thing
she goes because we kept them we have
evidence of this miracle huh yeah what
people hear these Miracles and and
they'll sort of laugh or write it off or
just dismiss them including Christians
and I sometimes wonder I say hold on you
believe that God the son became
incarnate and walked around and
performed public Miracles and then was
crucified and died and was buried and on
the third day rose again from the dead
and sojourned on Earth again for 40 days
performing so many miracles that Saint
John could not possibly record them all
because all those books would fill up
more than the entirety of the Earth but
you don't believe that your car keys
could have turned up in an improbable
place you don't believe that God could
multiply some pudding cups I think
where does the leap of faith jump in
here it seems they've already accepted
quite a lot I don't know I feel it's the
Newbie attitude
blessed are the unbelievers they will
not be disappointed
because part of believing is impactful
on seeing the miracle experience in the
miracle bringing forth a miracle Jesus
could do very little in his hometown not
because he couldn't do it because he's
Bound by his own rules of Providence
and so he has required that Faith be
part of him doing the Miracles
so if you're not going to believe you're
not going to see him unless you know he
has an incredible man of
love for you to the point of like Saul
of Tarsus where he's going to force you
to see yeah I mean sometimes
they'll do it